make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and just a little bit of an
update i'm actually going out of town
this weekend uh
starting on friday i think it is uh
myself and
i are going out of town for valentine's
day weekend so i've been looking for
comics that i want to cover to kind of
make up for stuff that we didn't finish
and different things like that
and and i know it sounds weird and kind
of out in left field but we're gonna do
more of the alien comics because i don't
know about you guys but i kind of get
tired of doing marvel in dc
and i love the idea of covering a story
that basically talks about what happens
after all the xenomorphs from like the
alien versus predator series
after all the xenomorphs conquer earth
because they did they basically took
over the world
in the alien in the alien comics you
guys will find a link down to the alien
videos in the description for like
nightmare asylum earth war
female war all that kind of stuff like
ripley and hicks and everybody it's all
just like popping off it's the craziest
thing it's amazing like it's just it's
amazing i'm getting excited just
thinking about it and here's the thing
all right so getting into black panther
here's the thing
man man i'm gonna tell you something
here's the thing here's the thing man
uh black panther is one of these
characters that if he's written
poorly ah it's bad bad bad bad bad
but if he's written correctly it is
it's some of the best comic book
storytelling in existence right now
here's the thing jeffrey thorne is
writing this he's the guy who took over
after
uh todd hattie coates and i was a little
a little skeptical i'm not going to lie
i was like
i don't know i mean tadahasi kosa's run
was amazing right the intergalactic
empire of wakanda
it was cool like he had a really really
great run and so then i get into this
issue dude jeffrey thorne knocked it out
of the
park dude this guy absolutely killed it
so here's the thing this initially opens
up with a lot of the black panther
stories where you get a kind of
monologue or inner discussion to a
degree but it focuses on a combination
of storm
and black panther now a lot of this was
based on the idea that storm
that really black panther himself is
kind of racing off to face off against
the the forces of null within wakanda
and that storm herself has basically
been overtaken
right now one of the things to keep in
mind is that when it comes to black
panther despite his marriage to storm
at the end of the day his role as a king
comes first so i wouldn't go as far as
to say he would leave storm to die
but i will go as far as to say that if
he has to make the choice between
saving the world or saving wakanda then
he'll save wakanda if he believes he can
keep it safe from whatever is out there
in the world and that's what's going on
here right now right that null has shown
up on earth he's
he's basically conquering the world and
black panther's like wakanda like
he immediately just like starts fighting
alongside his own forces back home
now the biggest problem with this is
that it's one of these things where the
the
different energy shields and so on and
stuff they have just aren't working that
nothing they have really seems to be
able to keep the forces
of null at bay and so at the end of the
day it just comes down to good
old-fashioned hand-to-hand combat now
here's a cool kind of a little tidbit
that we get here right this will be kind
of a running theme throughout this but
we get this this
line right and we we have this scenario
where like t'challa is talking to his
dad in the past but he kind of asks he
says you know t'challa take heed of what
i say
right he says every problem that you may
face every obstacle
in your way is susceptible to proper
planning plan
my son plan well with a sober mind with
an icy eye
duty knowledge honor loyalty justice
these are the cause of the panther clan
vast tells us victory lies in the mind
behind the claw the black panther
must be that mind but what of the claws
father t'challa responds
and he says oh my son we must always be
that as well and this is important
because this hits at the idea that when
it comes to being black panther that yes
there is a superhero aspect to it and
there is a child of doing things and
there's powers and stuff that come along
with it but it's one of these things
where as the black panther t'challa
is wakanda and the important thing to
understand behind that is
his people's willingness to rally behind
him is 100 contingent
on how they view him and so if they see
the black panther is somebody who's weak
in mind and body and spirit
they won't follow him and in fact
they'll actually rebel against him but
if the black panther is someone who is
strong
if he's always first in last out then
people know
they can count on him if he will fight
alongside them they know that he'll give
his life for them which means they can
honor that they can respect that and
they'll give their all when it comes to
any battle
and that's where t'challa has always
stood strong as a black panther he was
never the one to run from a fight he was
always the one to put his people first
even if it meant damning the world we've
seen that happen
multiple times over the course of marvel
comics and so it's this kind of
amazing moment because he he literally
like arrives and
rallies alongside all his soldiers right
and he's like warriors you know he's
like dawn you are sheath
rally to me it's epic as hell he's like
we cannot save the fallen
but by bass teeth no more of you
will fall and that right there just
rallies what's left of all these
soldiers and they managed to fight a lot
of these guys off but here's the problem
it's keeping the forces at null at bay
is starkly different
from defeating the forces of null and so
in this this great big huge war you know
if we can call it that they've won only
a battle and it'll only be a few minutes
before the forces the forces of knoll
begin to remuster
regather and they're back on the assault
again and so what we end up doing is we
switch over to
shuri now one thing to understand about
shuri in marvel
comics is that i'm i'm not the biggest
fan of what they're doing here and the
reason why
is because they're bringing her closer
in line with the version of shuri that
we saw in the marvel cinematic universe
but to be honest with you guys i was
not the biggest fan of shuri in the mcu
there's elements of her that i love the
fact that she's all about memes and
she's technologically capable and all
that kind of stuff and
by all standards of measurement even
seems to be light years ahead of iron
man but i loved
shuri in marvel comics because she was
battle-hardened she was hardcore
granted a lot of that didn't really
happen until do-more t'challa lost the
ability to become black
black panther she took his place and
then t'challa went on to become the king
of the dead so a lot of that didn't
really happen until you got to the tail
end of hickman's run or at least some of
the events that were coming into the
tail end of hickman's run so it kind of
makes sense to a degree but i'd really
love to see a blend
of the two now we kind of get this part
with her to a degree she is out there
fighting but in a lot of ways it's kind
of like she's using technology different
things like that
and it makes sense because she doesn't
really have the panther powers in the
traditional sense
i do i really do enjoy the shuri of
yesteryear right this
just hardcore battle-hardened chick but
it was just it was amazing the way that
she played out but
using the technology available to her
alongside okoye she's basically watching
everything
go down right and she's kind of picking
up on these small little things where
she's trying to mathematically
understand the best way to topple or at
least for the forces of wakanda to come
out on top and one of the things she
realizes is that because the symbiotes
intend to basically spread themselves as
opposed to arbitrarily killing then as
the numbers of wakandans decrease
the number of the of the forces of null
increase right so it's like fighting a
zombie infection for every member of
wakanda that falls
the forces of null increase by that
number of people and so it's almost like
this war of attrition right it's just
constantly going constantly going and so
if they don't find a way to end it soon
it's all going to come crashing down now
it's one of these things where t'challa
kind of enters in
and says yes like that's essentially
what it is right but there is another
way
because the discussion of shuri is we
have to abandon ship
right we can't stay here if we stay here
we're all going to fall and we're all
going to die now understand
shuri does not pitch the idea of bailing
out on wakanda
lightning this is not something that
she's just like oh my god things are
popping off run
free for your life that's not really
what she does right she doesn't really
throw it out there in in that way
it's just one of these things where it's
like we don't like from a mathematical
perspective
from my knowledge of science and alchemy
understanding all that kind of stuff we
just
don't really have any way to overcome
this but notice that as
shuri in the in the time that t'challa
has returned to being black panther
there's a lot of tools and things that
he has at his disposal that she doesn't
have
and one of the things that made t'challa
so capable is holding all these pieces
and having the mind to use them in the
right way makes a person
wildly capable and that's why he comes
in and he's like
no there is another way right there's
another way for us to basically win now
of course he's greeted by shuri who's
like yeah you survived you know and
okoye is like my king you know
i'm glad you're alive right he's
basically asked well while he's talking
to okoye and he's just like right into
the business of everything and trying to
figure out what they have to do
and say we need to get all those
survivors here to the royal city into
the royal chambers to keep them
protected from the forces of knoll all
that kind of stuff
sure he starts to pick up on something
and she starts to realize storm's not
there
and she asks where's storm and t'challa
turns around and just kind of says
aurora's no longer a factor
now there's the look of shock on the
face of a koi and the the look on
on shuri they know what it means but
here's the thing to understand if you're
new to the black panther mythos it's not
like t'challa's just like storm's dead
screw it i got better things to do
anyway it's a crushing experience to
know that the woman that he loves
is not that she's basically been
conquered by milk but in this moment and
given what we talked about in the
beginning that little bit of a monologue
where he was talking to his dad and
things like that
that it's focus on the task at hand do
not allow your mind to get
lost in what you could have done how you
could have achieved things all that kind
of stuff
focus on the task and that's one of the
beauty of the black panther stories
right because i know i don't know if you
guys are any anywhere like me but here's
the thing like i struggle with that
right and and i know there's some mirror
to the statement you know if you look at
your past and you don't trend you never
really live and that's kind of a joking
thing but like for real and for true
all of us are haunted by decisions we've
made over the course of our lives things
that we should have done that we didn't
do things that we did that we shouldn't
have done
and it in a lot of ways it just seems to
turn us upside down
right and it just rips us inside out and
that kind of anxiety and that kind of
adherence to decisions that were made in
the past that aren't really relevant
anymore
unless they have a direct effect on
what's happening right now seems to
anchor
us to this place where we're not really
able to move forward but the beauty of
the black panther mythos and with
t'challa himself the the kind of words
of wisdom he got from his father is
if you live in the past you'll never
ever go anywhere right you'll just be
stuck there
do not allow your mind to be locked down
into this one situation
focus on what needs to be done separate
yourself from the things that hold you
back
as hard as it might be as emotionally
crushing and
devastating as it might be you have to
because it'll be the only way for you to
achieve your goal especially when you're
in a time when you have to
fight when you have to find a way to
keep going when you're being faced on
all sides by
death and sadness and misery you have to
find a way to keep going and
looking at a way looking at a way to
guarantee victory is the only way to do
that
it's so important when it comes to the
black panther mythos because what he
ends up doing is actually pulling up one
of their one of their cameras
and showing that like one of the dragons
of knoll is swooping in and then
amplifies it by a thousand percent
and has all these people who are
basically being spewed on by this dragon
who's dumping all these symbiotes
everywhere people are converting into
the forces of null and that's when he
says
this is the fate that awaits us right
the shield will not protect us the
shield will not hold forever but we also
cannot abandon wakanda
we have to stay here because you have to
trust me i know
a way to save our country i know a way
to keep us alive
and to keep the forces of null at bay
seemingly
indefinitely and so what you end up
getting is the situation where he kind
of sends them off into various schemes
right he tells shuri
go to the vault right go to the vault
and and do your thing inside the vault
you know once once the plan is kind of
told to them because it's not really
told to us directly but he's like go to
the vault
do your thing and then he in turn tells
uh tells okoye
that she's going to pilot something
called the the claws of bass right the
hand of bass and this and let me tell
you something man do this do the the
hand of bass dude it's amazing it's like
this ridiculously amazing thing
i hope we get it in the marvel cinematic
universe because it is
beast right but in that moment okoye
brings down the shield right she she
steps into the room she brings up the
light she starts donning this this or
she picks up this kind of artifact and
then you have t'challa who actually goes
to a box
in kind of the throne room area and
pulls out what is basically
the sonic wave device of ulysses claw on
the surface we look at that and it might
just be like okay so that's his plan as
a sonic device he's literally going to
blast the simeones with sonics
well sure it could defeat venom but
against the forces of null it's not
going to do anything and you would be
100 right for believing that but don't
concern yourself with that because
it's actually not really what he's
planning he's planning for something
much grander and so what we end up doing
here is switching over to the jabari
people
and you've got them just fleeing for
their lives right all these these no
forces are just coming in they're just
they're just trying to
live man they're just they're just
fleeing for their life i don't mean it's
funny that like they're dying it's not
funny that they're dying but like
they're just they're just running
all over the place and then suddenly one
of the forces there are met by the
arrival of
shuri but the cool thing here is she's
appearing everywhere that she's got
these kind of little dolls so to speak
there's really
more magic and science blended together
in the form of alchemy but you can
basically cast your presence
in multiple places and fight in multiple
places and the reason why this is so
important is because
having shuri there the sister of black
panther there helps to rally those
forces
sure it's not as great as having
t'challa there but they also recognize
if he's not there
it's probably because he's working on
something else which shuri also
solidifies the problem with this and the
thing about this is that shuri out there
fighting
was only ever meant to be a temporary
measure that when she went out there
and got engaged in this conflict she
knew that a time would likely come
when she would be taken over by null and
that's exactly what happens
and so when that takes place black
panther t'challa chimes in directly to
okoye and says are you monitoring
everything
sure he's fallen and she's like yes it's
a time and he's like yes
deploy the hand of bass dude the hand of
bass comes out dude the hand of bass
comes out
it's the most beast ever man it's the
most beast thing ever she's literally
piloting
this giant hard light like panther man
it's amazing dude this thing is so cool
it's the coolest thing i've ever seen in
the in the black panther mythos it's
like a battle of the dragon zords right
she just comes jumping out and like
attacks the dragon
piloting this just giant panther dude
it's it is it's just like it's hard
light man it is so cool
it's like there's just this energy
construct and it's like damn i
really hope we get to see something like
that yeah here's here's the thing man
the black panther comics right now man
dude these comics slap it's amazing
these comics absolutely slept i'm sorry
i'm so excited people i'm sorry i'm so
excited but it is an exciting moment
it is an exciting moment in the black
panther comics man it is lit it's like
this thing is it's so lit
but but of course when that happens
while black panther's doing his thing
suddenly here comes shuri busting into
his room and the way this seemed to work
is that null kind of worked or at least
got his way to her directly through the
doll she was controlling that because
there were more or less facsimiles of
her
destroying those meant he could access
her now we're not really given the
details as to how
but we do know that null is one of these
guys who kind of operates on a higher
level with regards to telepathy
telekinesis
some measure of reality warping things
like that so how was he managing to get
a symbiote in there we don't fully know
because we're not fully aware exactly
how her artifacts work
and in all honesty it's not super
important because even when i was
reading it i was like i can just go with
it and it works right because she comes
busting in
as an agent of null and then starts
attacking t'challa now it's one of these
things where when he's using the device
of ulysses claw she kind of
of comes in you know almost sort of
pokes fun at him and is like is this
really the weapon that you're using is
this really your weapon of choice here
so what we end up doing is we sidetrack
for a second
and we go back to this conversation that
t'challa had with his dad when he was
younger and t'challa's dad is almost
kind of of chastising him and he's like
you ran away
from the the martial arts training for
the marshall training you were supposed
to be doing today
did is that really what happened and
t'challa says yes he says the test was
unfair
the teacher changed the rules and his
father's like did he really and he says
yes you know he says what rules were
those and he said it was to be a single
combat instead
there were five people who were there
three of them were jabari they were all
older than me
and one of them had a club and his
father says and they defeated you and he
says yes
he says they beat me father they hurt me
they cheated and he says you fought your
best though right one of the boys even
had to go to the healers did he not and
the response to chala is i lost i am the
prince one day i will be king
i cannot allow and his father stops him
and he says do you know the tale of bast
and the anansi drunk and he says yes he
says of course
and so this this is when the story gets
really cool right he says it is known
that bass was always jealous of her
younger brother anansi
the maker of secrets and stories bast is
the goddess of many things but also
she's curious as a cat she was forever
sneaking
into a nazi's workshop spying on his
creations one day a nazi had enough
he played a trick on his sister a nancy
wove a great drum
made of silk and stars and stories
dazzled by the side of it
vast could not help herself she pounced
upon the drum hoping to learn what a
nancy had hidden there but the drum
was not a drunk bast soon found herself
trapped inside
the more she struggled the more she was
covered in the threads of spider silk
soon she was wrapped all over it stuck
inside inside a nazi's drum
bass thrashed and screamed but a nancy
silk was strong
as powerful as she was vast nearly gave
up but then she realized that nancy's
web had not covered
her entire body one claw on one paw had
been left free
and so that's when you get into the the
the craziness of this
right the crazy that's when things get
bonkers because when shuri was making
fun of t'challa with him having this
thing he's like
no i mean that's not the case this is
not designed to be used as some kind of
a weapon some kind of a sonic device
and that's where it ends that's not the
entire the the basis behind this
he says you are a very powerful being
null you have all kinds of abilities at
your disposal this is true but you also
have
vulnerabilities electromagnetism high
frequency vibration wakanda mastered
both of those
centuries ago and no kind of blows him
off you know no no
operating through his sister kind of
blows him off which i guess really at
this point is just black panther versus
null right that's basically what it is
right no possessing a sister and then
fight you know facing off against black
panther and he's like it doesn't matter
right i'm gonna destroy you and consume
you the same way i consumed your sister
and he says
i think not right the barrier failed as
a shield that's
true but the the shield itself will make
as an
excellent amplifier and then he does the
coolest thing ever without even without
a without a shred of fear
without a shred of worry he just points
this claw at the sky and just says
goodbye null and that's when you pick
back up with the story right the bass
had stopped screaming
that bass had stopped twisting bass stop
thrashing with her one claw she began to
scratch a nancy's wet cutting through it
bit by bit until she was free and so
literally using this using this
amplifier
he just basically amplifies the power of
the shield which is which
between its its electromagnetic
properties
and the sonic vibrations of ulysses
weapon basically creates a giant
electromagnetic
sound barrier that null can't get
through that null cannot penetrate
that all the symbiotes consumed inside
of wakanda
are affected by this barrier and every
single person who was bonded to a
symbiote is freed the symbiotes in that
space
are totally destroyed as insane as it
sounds
is absolutely crazy and amazing as it
sounds
black panther has not only overpowered
null the symbiote god he's also
turned wakanda into the only safe refuge
on the face of the planet with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an
end if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you